It hurts. It's unbearable sometimes.
There have been many, many times
I've thought, I'm just quitting.
There have been so many occasions
when I've walked onto the ward
and it has been unsafe
because of the levels of staffing.
You feel devalued,
you feel a little bit worthless.
You feel like you're not appreciated
for what you do.
Adele is a junior doctor
in the UK's National Health Service
who walked out of her hospital
in a four-day strike in April,
which led to more than
195,000 missed appointments.
Claps don’t pay the bills,
claps don’t pay the bills.
In the first half of 2023,
the number of canceled appointments
amounted to almost half a million
as the medical sector took part
in the UK's union actions.
Over the past year, the UK has recorded
the largest number of strikes
since the 1980s, with sectors from health
care to postal service workers
and teachers all taking industrial action.
It is not a coincidence
that they come at a time
when the cost of living crisis
is cutting into the pockets of the nation,
with the cost of basic necessities
rocketing to new levels.
Industrial action is having
a serious impact
on the quality
of patient care.
Last week’s strike
by junior doctors caused
the cancelation of almost
200,000 operations and appointments.
The only thing we can really do is strike,
and the only cause
we can really legitimately strike
about is our pay.
But it's sort of an indicator
for loads of other stuff.
Junior doctors are asking for a
35% pay increase.
This round of pay negotiations
reflects both the acute squeeze
created by high inflation now
and more than a decade of inadequate
funding that has seen
public sector workers
fall way behind their private sector
counterparts.
So, junior doctors, their pay has increased
by about 16% in cash terms since 2008.
But in that same period, inflation
and other factors mean that
they’re actually 25% worse off,
and they’re just saying enough is enough.
I've been a junior doctor
for four years now.
I'm doing a ten-month long
contract in plastic surgery
just to get the experience
I need in order to try
and make a successful application
for my actual training post.
My current job has a higher base salary,
so it's about £40,000,
but I never do night shifts.
The extra hours, the night shifts,
they really do make up
the bulk of our salaries.
So when you factor all that together, I've
actually taken a pretty decent pay cut.
I will usually be scheduled
to work with one of the consultants
in the operating theaters.
Within plastic surgery, there's loads
of different things you could be doing.
There's hand surgeries.
You can do breast surgery,
so it's a lot of cancer surgery.
Plastic surgery includes burns.
So you might be doing skin grafting.
Plastic surgeons can do cleft lip
and palate surgery.
They can do head and neck surgery,
which is largely taking tumors.
At the moment, I'm on-call.
I started my on-call shift
on Saturday and I will go straight
through until this Friday.
And during those shifts
we then have to do trauma clinics.
So there's an awful lot of strain
within the NHS,
and the more people are struggling,
the more people are burning out.
Since I started work it’s
not been uncommon
to hear someone say that
one of their colleagues
has committed suicide.
According to the British Medical Association,
around seven in ten
junior doctors surveyed say they always
or frequently work in understaffed rotas,
which may be placing
patient and staff safety at risk.
Around half of junior doctors
described their desire to work in the NHS
in the next year as low or very low.
When you first move into a new house,
all sorts of things spring up
that you weren't expecting to pay for.
When I started my new job,
there was a mistake made
with my pay and it's taken five months
to get that resolved.
I've been consistently worrying
about money, consistently in my overdraft.
If any unexpected thing happens,
you always feel
just a heartbeat away
from absolute disaster, to be honest.
So when it comes to pay in the NHS,
the government says that it’s set
by these independent peer review bodies,
which they say they can't really interfere with.
These peer review bodies,
they will gather evidence
over the course of the year,
they give their recommendation
for maybe a two, three, five percent pay rise,
and although, you know,
these strikes are directed
at the government,
the government is trying to,
take their hands out of it
and say it's not really our deal.
At the same time,
we're getting in a bit of an impasse
right now. Junior doctors are asking for
what's called full pay restoration,
which would be a 35% pay rise right now.
The government is saying
that is completely unaffordable
and unacceptable
and they have to lower that.
You know, there are some things
that you see at work
or that you do at work
that if you were to say them
to a person who doesn't
work in health care,
they just wouldn't understand
why you're upset.
Did you work last night?
Yeah. So this is night
three of four for me.
So I'm slightly delirious,
but it’s OK, we're going to get through it.
So I think pay is a difficult issue.
On bank holidays, the person
in the hospital paid the least is
the F1, so the junior doctor
who's been a doctor for a year.
So you get paid more in the hospital
to clean toilets on a bank holiday.
It hasn't been safe for many years
and I don't think that will come
as a shock to anyone.
There is nowhere else
that a junior doctor can work.
We can't even work in private hospitals
because the reason people go
private is to ensure that
they get seen by a consultant.
So really our only options are ditch
the NHS entirely.
A lot of people have moved
to places like Australia
and New Zealand, where you are
valued more highly.
About two out of five
doctors said in a recent poll
that they are looking to leave the
NHS or would accept another job
if that was proposed.
And 80% are actually
saying that
they are constantly thinking
about ways out as well.
The ability to continue striking
is what's proving difficult because,
you know, we're striking
because we are not being paid enough
and we therefore don't
really have the ability
to take that much unpaid leave
from our work.
So I think the longer the strikes go
on, the more difficult it's going to be.
But I think the majority of people
have reached the point
where they are going to do anything
they have to in order to be able to
continue striking and making that point.
The fact that people are
still willing to fight
tells me that people have hope
that things will get better.